Hey everyone, I’m Ranjani, here to announce a new
series we’re starting called Missing Chapter!
The goal of this series is to tell stories
that often don’t make it into our history
textbooks — that are overlooked or underreported.
Our first season tackles stories of racial
injustice, political conflicts, even the hidden
history of US medical experimentation.
I’ll take you to the locations where these
historical events happened, dig up the evidence,
and meet the historians and locals who are
personally connected to these stories.
“Many people didn’t speak about it, they
kind of internalized it.”
“Wilmington did a really great job of covering
up a very dark past for a very long time.”
“Political power is truly seized by the
barrel of a gun.”
Through their voices and these stories, we’ll
revisit the past to give context to the present day.
A few months ago we put out a call for what stories you think we should tell with this series— and we
got hundreds of responses!
One of the suggestions we got the most was
the story of an 1898 American election and
coup d’etat in North Carolina.
And, that’s exactly what we’re covering
first.
We’re also trying something out for how
we’re publishing this first Missing Chapter story.
We're giving Vox Video Lab members early access, so they can watch this video right now.
If you want to get early access, you can
sign up by going to vox.com/join.
But don’t worry, this is not a paywall.
In one week, we’re going to publish
this video right here on the main channel
for all of our viewers.
Hope you enjoy the first episode!